from a historical standpoint is really  nice to play on a board that Fischer  studied and and played on it's really  good to get closer to him and you know  see his handwriting you know it's very  intimate and unfortunately I can't play  a strongest Fischer but we try the  objective of the game is the same as in  the game of chess although it's trickier  because unlike chess your pieces are not  really coming fast into the game you  can't just use your pattern recognition  and say oh this is good for me because  the pieces are randomly placed anyone  who plays shots in America aspires to be  like as influences lasting legacy it's  just tremendous without him we wouldn't  have the fighting spirit the fighting  chess I don't think we will ever have  mother's house and or everybody